1981 la guerre fait rage en afghanistan
d'un côté les troupes soviétiques qui
ont envahi le pays il ya deux ans de
l'autre l'armée islamique soutenu par
les etats-unis parmi ces chefs un homme
va devenir une légende
les téléspectateurs français font sa
connaissance le 28 décembre 1981 à leur
tête le commandant ahmad shah massoud
plébiscité par la population qui a pu
apprécier son courage et son
intelligence
ce chef de 28 ans assume des
responsabilités à la fois civile et
militaire
massoud par souci de sécurité ne dort
jamais deux nuits au même endroit avec
un sens de l'organisation a lié à une
volonté une discipline exemplaire il a
mis en place dans la vallée en moins de
deux ans des institutions politiques
fondées sur le respect de la démocratie
et la foi en l'islam sur ces images puni
clandestinement mme ashton n'a que 28
ans il est déjà une figure de la
résistance afghane en 1982 le chef des
moudjahidines répondait aux questions
d'un journaliste dans un français
impeccable
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser que vous
allez gagner je pense que nos gagnants
ça c'est clair
massoud voit juste 1989 l'armée
soviétique se retirent mais le pays
plonge dans une guerre civile qui oppose
plusieurs factions ethniques le
commandant et ses hommes en sortent
vainqueur en 1992 et prennent le
contrôle de kaboul la capitale afghane
après avoir fait la guerre le lion du
panchir doit maintenant construire la
paix
vous êtes content d'être à kaboul
aujourd'hui
joie de courte durée
1994 deuxième guerre civile avec
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle organisation
politique les talibans le lion du
panchir se pose encore une fois en tant
que chef de la résistance afghane il
tente de reprendre kaboul aux mains des
islamistes
on peut couper par l'arrière l'ennemi
madame l'euro ce côté là et pas vous
écouter vous sud est après l'offensive
face à la montée en puissance des
talibans le chef de guerre en appel à
l'aide de la communauté internationale
en avril 2001 massoud et à paris reçus
par le ministre des affaires étrangères
de l'époque hubert védrine la résistance
s'organisent de plus en plus au sein du
peuple afghan toutes ethnies confondues
tadjikes et hazara pachtoune ouzbek et
bientôt vous serez témoin d'un
soulèvement populaire contre les
talibans
le commandant massoud ne verra pas la
chute du régime taliban le 9 septembre
2001 il ya tout juste 20 ans il est
assassiné par deux membres d'al-qaïda
déguisés en journalistes à ses obsèques
son fils de 12 ans ahmad masood est
présent assis sur un char aujourd'hui il
a pris la relève de la résistance dans
la vallée du panjshir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]